[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
es knirscht in der Koalition
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck wirft der
FDP wortdruck vor weil die sein
heizungsgesetz erst mal ausgebremst hat
was geschah in Belgorod russland will
auf eigenem Gebiet ukrainische
Terroristen zurückgeschlagen haben
vieles ist aber noch unklar
und wir wollen noch mehr sagen die
deutschen Eishockeyspieler nach ihrem
klaren Sieg über Frankreich bei der WM
im Viertelfinale geht's gegen die
Schweiz
[Musik]
der geplante Austausch von Heizungen
wird zunehmend zur Belastungsprobe für
die Koalition Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck von den Grünen war auf der FDP
Wortbruch vor weil sie sich weigert das
Gesetz diese Woche im Bundestag zu
beraten der Plan war das ab Januar
möglichst jede neue Heizung mit 65%
Ökoenergie betrieben werden soll dazu
müsste das Gesetz aber noch vor der
Sommerpause im Bundestag verabschiedet
werden Winnie Hirscher
wohin steuert Christian Lindner hier mit
dem Zoll durch den Hamburger Hafen
Berlin sofern das Gebäude Energiegesetz
für Lindner noch ferner der FDP-Chef tut
so als habe er damit gar nichts zu tun
es liegt im Deutschen Bundestag ich bin
ja nur Regierung das ist jetzt im
Parlament sie haben keinen
mitspracherrecht was jetzt weitergeht im
Parlament
liegt's und kann nicht beraten werden
weil Lindners FDP den Gesetzentwurf
blockiert
es muss am Ende ein praktikables und
bezahlbares Gesetz sein und was keinen
Sinn machen würde ist horende Kosten
auszulösen bei den privaten Haushalten
die dann der Steuerzahler wieder
ausgleichen Mitte April hatte das
Kabinett den Entwurf einstimmig
beschlossen die FDP hatte danach zu
Protokoll gegeben was ihr daran
missfällt ihr Verhalten heute lässt die
Grünen deutlich werden das ist nicht
aufgesetzt wird ist aus meiner Sicht ein
Wortbruch mir ist die FDP und vielen von
uns sicher
in der Vergangenheit immer bekannt als
ehrlicher Kaufmann
das gilt jetzt offenbar für Christian
Lindner nicht mehr auch der
Bundeskanzler hatte zügige Umsetzung
angemahnt heute schweigt er die
Opposition fordert von ihm ein macht vor
Ort es wäre gut wenn der Bundeskanzler
bald möglich die Führung dieser
Koalition übernimmt und dafür sorgt dass
dieses Chaos ein Ende hat der
SPD-Fraktionschef der gestern gesagt hat
er sei genervt vom Verhalten der FDP
versucht zu deeskalieren Streit ist ein
großes Wort ich würde überhaupt nicht
über Streit reden sondern wir
diskutieren zu Zeit unterschiedliche
Wege fortsetzung folgt die
Verabschiedung des Gesetzes vor der
Sommerpause wird allerdings immer
unwahrscheinlicher
in Berlin blockiert dieser Streit jetzt
die Regierung
blockiert zumindest dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetz und das ist ja ernst genug
denn das ist eines der zentralen
Vorhaben der ampelregierung und der
klimagesetzung entsprechend schrill sind
ja auch die Töne geworden wenn Robert
Habeck der fdp-wort Pro und Verzögerung
vorwirft und Britta Hasselmann sogar die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Bundesregierung
in Frage stellt dann ist klar dass es
hier gerade um Kernbereiche dieser
Koalition geht für die Grünen steht die
Verlässlichkeit der Liberalen in Frage
und für die FDP gilt der vorgelegte
Gesetzentwurf als grundsätzlich neu
aufzustellen einfach zu viele Menschen
sein verunsichert dahinter dürfte auch
die liberale Sorge vor dem politischen
krisenpotenzial stecken aber natürlich
auch eigene profilierungsmöglichkeit
dennoch halte ich das Ganze zwar für
Ernst in der Sache aber nicht
schlussendlich ernst für den Bestand der
Koalition der Ruf nach einem Machtwort
des Kanzlers der wird hier in Berlin
allerdings lauter ähnlich ja wie schon
bei der AKW Laufzeitverlängerung
danke schön für diese Einschätzung aus
Berlin
der Energieversorgung bezeichnet
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck die
Windenergie an Land und will den Ausbau
vervierfachen klappen soll das mit mehr
Flächen mehr Fachkräften und schnelleren
Genehmigungsverfahren so die heute
vorgestellte Strategie erste positive
Signale sieht habe schon so sei der
Ausbau im vergangenen Jahr um 30%
gestiegen
vor großen Herausforderungen steht die
Regierung auch bei einem anderen Thema
dem Wohnungsbau ihr ausgegebenes Ziel
hat sie deutlich verfehlt eigentlich
wollte sie im vergangenen Jahr 400.000
neue Wohnungen bauen lassen das klappte
nicht trotz eines leichten Anstiegs
wurden es nur
295.300 die Gründe massiv gestiegene Bau
und auch Energiekosten außerdem fehlten
Fachkräfte und beim benötigten Material
gab es Lieferengpässe was das für den
Wohnungsmarkt bedeutet dazu Jürgen Kiel
Henningsdorf an der s-bahn-stunde bis
Berlin Mitte im Speckgürtel der
Hauptstadt wird kräftig gebaut doch der
Traum von den eigenen vier Wänden wird
für Familien wegen der steigenden
Bauzinsen auch hier immer teurer der
Bund will jetzt gegen steuern und
startet am 1 Juni ein neues
Förderprogramm wir wollen wir helfen
Familien mit einem bis zu versteuernden
Einkommen von 60.000 Euro jeweils dann
in Schritten erhöht pro Kind um 10.000
Euro und das soll dazu beitragen dass
diese Familien auch in Zukunft
Wohneigentum bilden können das
Hauptproblem aktuell steigende Baukosten
2020 waren sie noch stabil dann
kletterten sie im Jahresvergleich
kräftig im letzten Quartal kam wieder
zusätzliche 15% oben drauf
wenn die steigenden Baukosten dann auf
die neuen mieten umgelegt werden könne
das nicht gut gehen warnen
Sozialverbände na was uns fehlt ist
natürlich ein gemeinnütziger Sektor am
Wohnungsmarkt wir brauchen dringend eine
neue wohngemeinnützigkeit also ein nicht
gewinnorientierten Sektor dessen Ziel es
ist schnell und gut zu bauen für die
Menschen in Hennigsdorf funktioniert das
ansatzweise die meisten Mietwohnungen
bauen hier städtische und
genossenschaftliche gesellschaftschaften
gerne hätte die Stadt noch mehr doch es
scheitert oft auch an den Vorschriften
wenn solche sozial angebundenen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften bauen wollen
dann soll man sie einfach machen lassen
allerdings die Vergangenheit hat gezeigt
die Anforderung werden eher immer mehr
weniger Bürokratie könnte dem Markt mit
Sicherheit helfen dieser Berliner Neubau
brauchte vom Bauantrag bis zum ersten
Spatenstich 26 Jahre
wir kommen jetzt zu einem politischen
Jubiläum Deutschlands
älteste Partei die SPD ist 160 Jahre alt
geworden gefeiert wurde in der
Parteizentrale im Willy-Brandt-Haus in
Berlin Bundeskanzler Scholz rief seine
Partei auf für eine Gesellschaft des
Respekts zu kämpfen und den Klimaschutz
nicht den Grünen zu überlassen im
Mittelpunkt stand aber die Geschichte
der Partei am 23 mai 1963 gründete
Ferdinand Lassalle den allgemeinen
deutschen Arbeiterverein ein Vorläufer
der heutigen SPD
spätestens seit einer großrazia im
Winter beobachten deutsche Ermittler die
Szene der Reichsbürger besonders
aufmerksam drei weitere sitzen jetzt in
Untersuchungshaft zwei würden dem
Ermittlungsrichter beim
Bundesgerichtshof in Karlsruhe
vorgeführt die Verdächtigen sollen zu
der Gruppe um den Geschäftsmann Heinrich
prinzreuß gehören der seit Dezember in
Haft ist und da seiner Führung so der
Vorwurf wollten die Reichsbürger die
Regierung stürzen und die Demokratie
abschaffen
die EU versucht der Ukraine bei der
Verteidigung gegen Russland zu helfen
mit Geld und Waffen nach Angaben der
Kommission flossen in diesem Jahr bisher
7,5 Milliarden Euro damit Löhne
Krankenhäuser und Schulen finanziert
werden können über die weitere
militärische Hilfe berieten heute die
Verteidigungsminister versprochen sind
eine Million Artillerie Geschosse
diskutiert werden F16 Kampfjets Florian
neuhahn
es ist das am meisten exportierte
Kampfflugzeug der Welt die Ukraine aber
hat den US-amerikanischen F16 Kampfjet
bisher nicht bekommen doch nach dem
grünen Licht aus Washington ist der
erste Schritt dahin nur noch eine Frage
von Tagen wie Ausbildung von
ukrainischen Piloten etwa in den
Niederlanden oder in Polen
es hat noch nicht begonnen aber ja wir
sind bereit mit dem Training loszulegen
Deutschland verfügt über keine F16
Kampfjets könnte aber bei der Ausbildung
helfen in Brüssel beim
Verteidigungsminister Treffen der EU
schließt der deutsche Minister eine
solche Unterstützung nicht mehr aus wie
ein paar Möglichkeiten die es
theoretisch geben könnte die prüfen wir
gerade und dann werden wir sagen ob wir
diesen Beitrag leisten können und wollen
was die EU leisten kann das wird derweil
bei einem anderen Thema hinterfragt der
Munition eine Million Geschosse in einem
Jahr das hatte Europa versprochen doch
EU interner Streit und Produktions-
Verletzung heute meldet der
EU-Außenbeauftragte also die letzten
Zahlen sehen deutlich besser aus als
noch vor zehn Tagen die Mitgliedstaaten
haben bisher 220.000 Artillerie
Geschosse an die Ukraine geliefert und
ich dachte das ist ein Fünftel der
zugesagten Menge doch schon türmt sich
das nächste Problem auf die für die
militärische Unterstützung vorgesehenen
Gelder sind aufgebraucht und eine
Erhöhung wird aktuell von Ungarn
blockiert Europa liefert also aber
weiter im eigenen europäischen Tempo
den zweiten Tag in Folge hat es nahe der
ukrainischen Grenze Kämpfe auf
russischem Boden gegeben genauer gesagt
in der Region Belgorod Russland macht
ukrainische Nationalisten für die
Angriffe verantwortlich und behauptet
die Angreifer zurückgedrängt zu haben
die Ukraine hingegen spricht von
russischen Dissidenten die gegen Putin
aufgeklärten Christian Volk
es ist Montag Vormittag als die ersten
Kämpfer mit den gelb-blauen Ukraine
Farben in Russland auftauchen sie
zerstören offenbar einen Grenzübergang
schreiben Grüße aus bachmut an die
Hauswand die Ukraine dementiert sie
seien nicht verantwortlich stattdessen
behaupten zwei russische Milizen dass
sie ihr eigenes Land angreifen
wir wollen dass unsere Kinder in Frieden
aufwachsen und freie Menschen werden
damit sie reisen studieren und einfach
in einem freien Land glücklich sein
können aber das hat keinen Platz im
heutigen Putin Russland von beiden
Organisationen hat man schon in der
Vergangenheit gehört die haben sich
unterschiedlich dazu bekannt dass sie
Putin und den Krieg nicht unterstützen
und es gab ja auch schon der
Vergangenheit die Besetzung von einem
Gebäude es gab entgleiste Züge es gab
anschlüge Anschläge auf Bahnen Schienen
auf Gleisanlagen in der in Russland
in den russischen Nachrichten die
Grenzregion ruft Terroralarm aus die
russische Armee liefert sich heftige
Gefechte mit den Angreifern Moskau
spricht von ukrainischen Extremisten die
man letztendlich abgewehrt habe
die Bemühungen gehen weiter die
spezialoperation wird fortgesetzt um
solche Übergriffe in Zukunft zu
verhindern
eine von Russland inszenierte Aktion
halten Sicherheitsexperten für
unwahrscheinlich vielmehr sei das Ziel
der Pro ukrainischen Truppen die
russische Armee im eigenen Land zu
beschäftigen und von der Front
fernzuhalten laut Moskau sind neben dem
Grenzschutz nun auch Luftwaffe und
Artillerie in der russischen Region
stationiert
wie viele Kinder in Deutschland
Opfer sexueller Gewalt werden weiß
niemand genau weil viele Schicksale gar
nicht ans Licht kommen doch schon die
Zahl der erfassten Fälle erschüttert
nach Angaben des Bundeskriminalamts sind
es jeden Tag 48 Kinder und Jugendliche
zwar sind die Opferzahlen leicht
zurückgegangen auf
17.437 sie bleiben aber auf hohem Niveau
stark angestiegen ist die Zahl der
missbrauchsdarstellungen und auch die
Zahl der Kinder und Jugendlichen die
solche Inhalte besitzen oder verbreiten
Britta Spiekermann berichtet
in der Altersgruppe der 10 bis
18-Jährigen haben inzwischen fast alle
ein Smartphone hier in dem Spot einer
Kinderschutzorganisation werden die
Gefahren dargestellt etwa der Austausch
von Nacktbildern aber auch von
pornografischen und
missbrauchsdarstellungen Chats vielen
Kindern und Jugendlichen ist nicht klar
dass sie sich strafbar machen und in das
Visier von Ermittlern geraten das ist
der Hauptgrund warum sich laut jüngsten
Bericht des Bundeskriminalamtes die Zahl
der Tatverdächtigen seit 2018 März
verzweifacht hat häufig sind es weniger
schwerwiegende Fälle doch sie werden als
Verbrechen eingestuft und blockieren
Ermittlungsbehörden und Gerichte es
braucht eine Korrektur damit Fälle mit
geringem Unrechtsgehalt künftig wieder
frühzeitig eingestellt werden können und
damit taten die einen eindeutig
ausbeuterischen Kontext haben damit das
weiterhin konsequent und mit hohen
Strafen geahndet werden kann nach den
Missbrauchsfällen von lüchte Bergisch
Gladbach und Münster war das Strafrecht
2021 unter der damaligen
Bundesjustizministerin Lambrecht
verschärft worden nach einigen zögern
will der jetzige Justizminister
Buschmann in diesem Jahr einen
Reformvorschlag vorlegen auch in einer
anderen juristischen Frage sieht das
Bundeskriminalamt seit Jahren dringenden
Handlungsbedarf bei der Speicherung von
IP-Adressen und Tatverdächtige zu
identifizieren
in vielen Fällen ist der ist die
IP-Adresse der einzige Ermittlungsansatz
und kann dieser nicht verfolgt werden
müssen Verfahren eingestellt werden mit
dem Risiko das Missbrauchstaten nicht
unterbunden werden können die Blicke der
Experten richten sich auf die Politik
insbesondere auf das
Bundesjustizministerium im Fokus müsste
das Wohl von Kindern und Jugendlichen
stehen
viele Bahnreisende waren erleichtert als
der Streik letzte Woche noch abgesagt
wurde seit heute verwandeln die Bahn und
die Gewerkschaft EVG wieder die EVG will
zwölf Prozent mehr Lohn mindestens aber
650 Euro im Monat bei einer Laufzeit von
12 Monaten die Arbeitgeber bieten eine
inflationsausgleichsprämie dazu
Steigerungen von insgesamt zehn Prozent
für die unteren und mittleren Einkommen
sowie 8% für die höheren die Bahn will
eine deutlich längere Laufzeit von 27
Monaten die Tarifgespräche in Fulda
beobachtet für uns Stefan Schlösser
Stefan warum könnte das diesmal klappen
mit einer Einigung die er weitere
Streiks ersparen würde
die Ausgangslage ist einfach viel besser
als bei den drei Verhandlungsrunden
zuvor sie reden tatsächlich miteinander
und das allein ist ja schon was neues
bisher war es immer so da war schon noch
kurzer Zeit Schluss inhaltlich wurde gar
nicht richtig miteinander verhandelt es
gab nur gegenseitige Vorwürfe aber mit
dem Vergleich vom Frankfurter
Arbeitsgericht als man diesen
Streitpunkten Mindestlohn endlich
ausräumen konnte damit hat man endlich
eine gemeinsame Verhandlungsbasis
geschaffen Inhalte liegt man natürlich
trotzdem noch weit auseinander die von
den Bahn die von der Bahn angebotenen
10% mehr Lohn die klingen zwar ganz
ordentlich sind aber beispielsweise beim
Gehalt von 2500 € nur 250 € mehr und
nicht die geforderten 650 Euro und das
bei einer Laufzeit von 27 Monaten das
heißt auf ein Jahr gerechnet sind es
dann keine 5% mehr also die Bahn wird
sich sicherlich noch mal ordentlich
bewegen müssen und jetzt heißt es sich
irgendwie in der Mitte einigen klingt
irgendwie einfach aber natürlich wird
das noch ein sehr sehr Ringen sein und
am Ende aus Sicht der Bahnreisenden
hoffentlich am Ende auch gelingen denn
weitere Streiks die braucht tatsächlich
niemand mehr danke schön Schwester nach
Fulda
und jetzt noch der Blick nach Mexiko wo
der Vulkan popocatepetitel weiter vor
sich hin brodelt seit Tagen spuckt er
Gas und Aschewolken hier Bilder einer
mexikanischen Webcam ein großer Ausbruch
wird nicht erwartet aber der Ascheregen
beeinträchtigt das Leben der Menschen
sie wurden aufgefordert sich für eine
Evakuierung bereit zu machen Schulen
wurden bereits geschlossen
und sollten Sie sich vorhin beim 160
geburtstag der SPD gewundert haben ja
die wurde natürlich
1863 von Ferdinand lassal gegründet und
nicht 1963 ich bitte das zu
entschuldigen und jetzt sind wir bei der
Eishockey WM Norbert die deutsche Crew
darf sich aufs Viertelfinale freuen ja
durch den Sieg gegen Frankreich und das
hat er ja auch der neue deutsche
Bundestrainer Harald Kreis als mindest
Ziel ausgegeben heute das letzte
forenspiel eben ein souveräner 15.07
gegen Frankreich und im Viertelfinale
geht's dann am Donnerstag gegen die
Schweiz
es ist der vierte Sieg nacheinander
schon nach vier Minuten führt das
DEB-Team durch Alexander ehlwald
stachowiakballons und übersichtbehält
kurios das 2:0 durch den linken Fuß von
tiffits das zählt weil ohne kickbewegung
angeschossen von Peter und dieser GG
avanciert mit seinem vierten Tor bei
dieser WM zum Top Scorer im deutschen
Team das optimistisch ins Viertelfinale
geht die Schweizer sagen selber das ist
vielleicht die beste Mannschaft diese
hier auf einen Weltmeisterschaft
schicken konnten ich will eine sehr
starke Vorrunde für heute Niederberger
das erste zu Nullspiel dieser WM kein
schlechtes Omen
Borussia oder Bayern das ist die Frage
die alle Fußballfans hierzulande bewegt
am Samstag entscheidet sich ob
Tabellenführer Dortmund oder Verfolger
München Meister wird und am Sonntag wird
gefeiert beim BVB könnte das ungefähr so
aussehen
vor zwei Jahren galt Edin tersitsch beim
Pokalsieg nur als Zwischenlösung den
Geschmack des Erfolges könnte er nun
auch als voll anerkannter Meistertrainer
Kosten nachdem sie in Augsburg laufen
die Vorbereitungen zur meisterkrönung
auf Hochtouren ein prallvolles Stadion
natürlich aber kein Public Viewing in
der Stadt die werden da gemeinsam
Meister feiern geht es dann allerdings
eher ja dezentral in Rudel Viewing wie
das neue Deutsch heißt macht das auch
Sinn im Erfolgsfall Ergebnis am Sonntag
auf altbekanntem Kurs durch die
Innenstadt ein Korso wie letztes 2012
unter Trainer jungtopf mindestens
200.000 Zuschauer werden entlang der
Traditionsstrecke erwartet und an einer
Bierdusche für den neuen Meistertrainer
dürfte es dann auch nicht fehlen
die Bayern haben natürlich auch eine
Meisterschaftsfeier geplant Sonntag
Nachmittag auf dem Marienplatz schauen
wir einfach mal spannend ja morgen wird
der kühlste Tag der Woche sagt Christa
Augen und erzählt gleich wie es mit dem
Wetter weitergeht das heute journal um
9:45 Uhr mit Maria Slomka wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen entspannten Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auch wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend morgen wird der kühlste
Tag der Woche schon heute war es ja
teils 10 Grad kühler als noch gestern
und morgen bekommen wir es dann mit
einem richtigen kaltluftropfen zu tun so
nennen wir dieses kleine Höhentief dass
ich jetzt von dem tiefen Druck im Norden
abspaltet und genau über uns hinwegzieht
und so wird es auch in der Nacht kühl
bei Aufklaren in den Mittelgebirgen
sinken die Werte auf zwei Grad dann
kommt auch wieder Bodenfrost mit ins
Spiel unter den Wolken bleibt es bei 8
bis 13 Grad das ist zum einen an den
Alpen der Fall da gibt es anfangs auch
noch gewittrige Schauer auch an den
Küsten ist es häufig bewölkt und der
noch lebhafte Nordwestwind bringt neue
Schauer und diese Schauer und Dichterin
Wolken die verlagern sich dann morgen im
Laufe des Tages immer weiter Richtung
Mitte allzu viele felte aber nicht raus
der Wind lässt etwas nach und später
kommen direkt an den Küsten und im
Nordosten wieder die Sonne etwas raus am
meisten Sonne finden wir morgen in den
südwestlichen Landesteilen direkt an den
Alpen bleibt es aber bei den Schauer
Wolken da kann dann nachmittags auch mal
ein kräftiges Gewitter mit dabei sein
und ist eben kühlen Morgen 13 Grad im
höheren Bergland und mit Ach und Krach
am Rhein noch mal 20 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen bleibt es bei den
Schauern an den Alpen aber es setzt sich
doch immer mehr die Sonne durch und am
Samstag vor Pfingsten sind immerhin
wieder 15 bis 24 Grad möglich tschüss